pluta
foreign
mercy eric and
good afternoon everybody and as said by
president ozil from the line yesterday
at the european hydrogen week clean
hydrogen will have a central place in
the climate neutral economy of the
future
ndu is the world's clean hydrogen
trailblazer today during the hydrogen
week the european clean hydrogen
alliance
announced the pipeline of viable
investment projects in clean hydrogen it
will allow to have a clear picture of
all hydrogen related initiatives in
europe linking ideas with potential
investors
the pipeline collects over 750 projects
ranging from clean hydrogen production
to its use in industry mobility energy
and buildings located in all four
corners of europe
the list of projects is available online
and searchable by project type location
company and start date and as always you
find more information in our daily news
thank you
conference
depressed lastly let me welcome a
visitor group that we have today a group
of journalists from
cyprus and let me wish you kalimer
and with that the floor is yours
so
vince
a question
thank you eric i hope you can hear me
go ahead you got me go thanks um a
question on libya uh the commission's
2020 africa strategy calls for an
approach to migration that is based on
the respect for human rights and
international law
so i wanted to ask if the commission has
any response to reporting this week in
the new yorker which documented torture
rape and murder at eu supported
facilities in libya and i wondered if it
had any response to reports of aid
diversion where eu funds from the
emergency trust fund
going to militias i wanted to ask
whether the commission
thinks that the status quo is acceptable
and if not what it's doing to change it
thank you
peter
thank you vince
well when it comes to our cooperation
with the libya in terms of
migration let me underline maybe two
things one is uh what the new yorker
wrote is uh is not really true i mean
the allegations raised there are not two
i'm uh i can i can push very strongly
back on them the
logic and the sense of our cooperation
with libya is to save lives we are not
channeling funds to any of the
organizations in libya to any of the
militias our the nature of our
cooperation with libyan coast guard and
other entities in libya is to save lives
to provide them equipment and training
in order for them to be able to save
people
in their territorial waters and in the
area of search and rescue in the in
search and rescue area of the of the
libyan authorities of course nothing in
libya is ideal but one has to see the
situation in libya in the context of the
conflict which has been ongoing there
for almost 10 years and is now hopefully
on the way to be solved so once there is
a sustainable peaceful solution found in
libya then it will be possible to tackle
properly based on how we would wish
ideally the situation to develop also
other issues which have something to do
with libya including the migration but
at this stage what we were doing until
now with libya was in the context of the
ongoing conflict with the context of us
not having access to libyan territorial
waters and to the search and rescue area
of libyan forces of libyan entities and
our priority was to save lives and to
train the libyan coast guard uh in order
to save people who are shipwrecking or
who are uh who are at the risk of
drowning in in libyan territorial waters
or in libyan search and rescue areas and
the money which was given was to provide
training so that they know how to how to
save them and also how to raise their
awareness how to treat people respecting
their lives when it comes to issues such
as detention centers we said many very
many times how we are working also with
international organizations and libyan
authorities to close all the illegal
detention centers where the situation of
the migrants held there is absolutely
inhumane and we continue to do so and we
engage with libyan authorities but as i
said libya has to be seen as a country
in a conflict and and once this conflict
will be settled for good then it will be
it will be possible to make also the
necessary improvements when it comes to
managing the migration
vince you have a follow-up
yes thank you um
it's it's striking to me that you say
that the new yorker was wrong because
obviously they have a fact-checking
department that's probably bigger than
most bureaus so i'd be interested to
know exactly where they were wrong
because the commission was quoted in the
story um but on my question was really
about the facilities themselves in in
libya and you said you're working to
close illegal facilities does that imply
that the legal ones are and what's going
on in the legal ones um or whatever you
understand that those wants to be
are acceptable
again when it comes to managing the
migration in context of the libya
nothings is nothing is ideal so we hope
that with uh with the stabilization of
the situation we will be step by step
able to deal also with other issues
regarding also uh to to migration on
where new yorker is wrong is to accuse
the eu that we were creating some kind
of shadowy illegal uh immigration system
in libya that's simply not true the
objective and the main logic of our
engagement with libyan partners all
along all along since the start of our
cooperation was to save lives to prevent
people dying in the mediterranean waters
that's it and on the detention centers
we would wish to see the
detention centers which are being used
for illegal activities to be closed and
all the other detention centers which
are run i don't want to say the word
legitimate but which iran in a way that
the libyan authorities see fit currently
we press the libyan authorities together
with international organizations to
provide human for human conditions for
people being being held there
thank you other other questions for
peter on
this issue
concerning libya
please only keep your hand raised if
your question concerns this
i see that on the chapter different
hands raids which are not linked to this
mosey your hand is raised do you have a
question on libya
i had another question but take
opportunity to ask a quick question to
to peter on libya
because i remember very well that the
issue of illegal detention centers libya
was raised more than a year ago and they
were supposed to be closed so i guess
they are not being closed yet does this
mean also that the eu and other
organizations have no access to those
centers in order to supervise what is
going on there thank you
well indeed i mean there are places
where we don't have access again
remember it was very difficult over the
past years to gain access to libya for
security reasons because of the raging
conflict but now with the with the
improved circumstances on the ground
with the ongoing peace process uh that
will hopefully
be brought to a successful end starting
with the elections which are scheduled
for the 24th of december uh we hope to
be able to work even more intensively
with libyan authorities also to work on
improvements of all the things which are
not ideal currently when it comes to
migration
messi
other questions on
libya
i see one hand raised in the chat no
so other questions on foreign policy for
peter
lukash
yes i had a question um
about ukraine
what can you say and
what do you know what is happening on
the eastern part of ukraine i'm thinking
about a gathering of the
russian troops on the eastern part of
this country thank you
thank you lukash indeed
all the indication and information
regarding the military buildup by russia
at the ukrainian border is very worrying
we've been discussing this issue for
some time already we are in contact and
coordination also with our transatlantic
partners there are diplomatic activities
going on at various for us currently you
see the the meeting of the nato in riga
we will have the oec ministerial meeting
in stockholm tomorrow the high
representative borel is meeting the
prime minister of ukraine mr smiha today
exactly to discuss this uh this
situation to see what the european union
can do in order to increase the
resilience of this very important
neighbor and strategic partner of the
european union
lucas your hand is still raised you have
a follow-up
lucas
yes i have a follow-up
i would like to know whether high
representative has any contact recently
with the russian authorities on that
matter thank you
well we are in contact with russian
partners as we always are um through
various levels and various channels most
recent contacts include the contacts at
the higher level in order to see how we
can organize a meeting between the high
representative and minister lavrov so
there are contacts ongoing i can maybe
add one thing that when we are talking
about ukraine one thing has to be very
clear when it comes to european union we
continue our firm and unchanged support
to ukraine's territorial integrity and
sovereignty this is uh part of our
policy and by the way respect for
territorial integrity and sovereignty is
also
part of the basic principles of the
helsinki final act that means of oec
membership russia is also also the
member so all these things are very
important and they are feeding into
ongoing contacts when we are dealing
with this situation and the european
union foreign ministers will be
discussing uh these recent developments
also at the upcoming foreign affairs
council
other questions on ukraine and russia
no other foreign affairs related
questions william
adding the ft
uh the ft oh sorry
no we could both see and hear you so go
ahead
hello
not sure i pronounced the name correctly
apologies for that but you have the four
the eu plan to spend 300 million to uh
infrastructure to counter china this is
an ft report is that i don't know is
this eu's intention to counter china by
building infrastructure outside the eu
or just helping other countries can you
make clear clarify on that
thank you very much i think you are
referring to the articles that relate to
the global gateway communication that
will be adopted by the college tomorrow
and will be presented as as i have just
said
by
president uh van der laan
we know that
infrastructure
communications
are essential elements of modern life
and
the commission is therefore
intent on ensuring that we can cooperate
with our partners across the globe in
this in this area
constructively and this is what we will
be presenting tomorrow
other questions on foreign affairs
foreign affairs yes please
um thank you uh my question is regarding
colombia um the representative gilmore
was in colombia last week to check
the advances of the
agreement five years after the signature
and he said uh that uh colombia should
stop on uh the failure language
into this agreement as well as u.n
secretary guterres said on the visit
but
there are issues that the colombian
population is concerned about and it's
uh the 300 former guerrilla members that
have been murdered in this
five years and some points that have not
been uh well implemented of the
agreement so the european union is
analyzing all these
topics and how do you foresee that the
agreement will be implemented in the
upcoming years
this would be
this would be a question more for uh
nagila
for you oh sorry sorry sorry
i can confuse in my portfolio location
go ahead
on columbia we said already last week
that uh we really um celebrate with the
colombians the fifth anniversary of this
very important peace agreement that
already saved so many lives in a country
which was so badly damaged by this uh by
this ongoing conflict for the past
decades and the european union supports
this deal because it turns out that this
could actually uh serve as a model for
the world how to how to
deal with the issues internal issues and
solve them and we are fully committed
and we firmly support the full
implementation of this deal and this is
what we are conveying to our colombian
partners and we stand by colombia as it
is implementing this very important
piece deal
other questions on this issue
no so other foreign affairs issues anna
danske i think that my question is more
for nabila because it concerns
uh south africa and president rama fosa
ask you a question and let's see okay
are so there was a sharp criticism of
south african president rama fosa on the
decision uh to ban the flights and he
said that it's against the engagement
because there was an engagement in
solidarity
that goes against it and he said also
that instead of thanking south africa
for the excellent work of the scientists
they feel punished and this punishment
also is an economic blow because are
there they were expected tourists this
season because for south africa is a
touristic season and now they have
double blow they have political blow
they have economic blow and of course
that resonates also in hearts of many
africans that's why i would like to have
a reaction of the european commission
thank you this is actually more a
question for adelbert so we will come
back to it afterwards okay
but we note your question and we'll come
back to it are there other questions on
um let me on foreign affairs issues that
are under peter or navila's
responsibility i see three hands raised
in the chat so we'll go there
the problem technically
um
possible
um
training missions
hi this is for peter i think
do we have an update on the options
figure on varusha i.e one can we expect
it to be circulated ahead of the next
corporate and fac thanks
go ahead
sorry
we have a ballet
of our spokes
it will be very short in any case yes
thank you for the question well the
update is that uh the paper is being
finalized and as the high representative
said uh in the press conference after
the last foreign first council it will
be submitted to the member states first
all right other questions on this issue
george you have a follow-up
uh just a short follow-up on this
um uh
kudo will be expecting this this week or
next week just to have a specific time
frame on this thanks
again this tasking was given to the hrvp
by the member states by the foreign
minister so he will be responding to the
foreign ministers first
and as he indicated it would happen in
december
thank you
okay um george i still see your hand
raised no good okay we move on to other
foreign affairs
issues yes
my question on afghanistan
uh eu during
doha
dialogue suggested
to taliban that
they should release salaries of
government
servant in afghanistan
moreover
taliban actually during talks in doha
also
recommitted to allowing people
of foreigners in afghan who want to
leave afghanistan
but they
conditioned that their airport
should be maintained and
operational and they need assistance
from eu to do so
so your comments on that thank you
uh
thanks a lot khalid for your question i
mean the only thing i can do is recall
to you uh what was already said in the
press release following the talks
in
in in doha
where
both sides underline the necessity of
humanitarian access of men and women
participating in assessing the needs for
and delivery of human rights of
humanitarian assistance to
ensure equal access for women
men and children the eu delegation
welcomed also the confirmation by the
afghan delegation that humanitarian and
humanitarian plus
assistance
will not be subject to taxation and of
course as you said the afghan delegation
recalled its commitment to resume the
payment of salaries to all servants
who in many cases have not received
their salary since may having said that
when it comes to humanitarian plus and
humanitarian
aid to to afghan afghanistan and all
what comes underneath maybe my
colleagues can give you more details as
to what falls under this yes but we will
do this if you don't mind bilaterally
because time is uh running we've already
been uh
half an hour on foreign affairs let me
see if there's any last question on
foreign affairs for us
today
yes and we had the china question as
well from oliver yes so on the airport
uh just was to say that uh that there
was no formal request uh really
um so um
the issues of operation of airports were
were mentioned as you said but they were
not discussed in in detail so i would
i would refer you again to
the
press release
and we had a question from oliver on
china
oliver perhaps you could repeat your
question now that we have
finished the other themes go ahead
yeah hi sorry uh no the question is
simply there's there's a report by
reuters uh
that's a huge province in china henan i
think is introducing
a massive surveillance system whereby
they are going to systematically
uh
you know
electronically
basically set up a database of
journalists or foreign students of
anyone who might be
a supposed uh threat to the to the
regime and my idea uh or actually my
question is what the european commission
would do about this it might affect
european journalists it might affect
european
citizens starting there or working there
thank you
oliver i'm afraid we'll have to come
back to you because we're not aware of
this
of this issue and report so we will look
into it and see if there is anything
that we can say
thank you very much okay we close the
foreign affairs
chapter today and i go to thomas who has
been very patient
thomas go ahead
no problem
um
uh
issued the following statement and i
quote
my initiative to draft guidelines as an
internal document for communication by
commission staff in their duties was
intended to achieve an important aim
to illustrate the diversity of european
culture
and showcase the inclusive nature of the
european commission towards all walks of
lives
all walks of life and beliefs of
european citizens
however the version of the guidelines
published does not adequately serve this
purpose
it is not a mature document
and does not meet all commission quality
standards
the guidelines clearly need more work
i therefore withdraw the guidelines and
we'll work further on this document
uh
follow up
um
communication
um
um
i see no other questions on this subject
thank you very much um
we move or is there another so please
only keep your hand raised
on the interaction platform if you have
a question on this issue
thank you it's not the case so i move to
moses who has been asking for the floor
thank you christian
okay yes eric thank you very much
i try to be very brief this time
and i'm referring to this morning's
release uh
from the commission about
let's say a new mandate to a new role
for ecdc
you know the center for disease
prevention and control so my question is
what you say would you say that this new
role is a direct result
of the lessons learned during the
chronovirus crisis crisis and linked to
that those other issues raised in the
press announcement about the
european
health union
which needs to be found finalized
understand and then my question is can
you please explain
the state of play as regards the
political talks
between institutions on the commission's
proposals on european
health council health union thank you
thank you question for stefan
um thank you very much mosey
indeed we are we welcome very much the
agreement that has been reached with
regard to the ecdc
one of the lessons learned in the
pandemic is that we need to learn
lessons obviously from the way we have
handled the pandemic in the last 18 20
months and the ecdc proposal that we
introduced was one of the many proposals
we did to indeed strengthen this
european health union in addition to
strengthening the ecdc we also had a
proposal for instance to
strengthen the
ema and as you know we also have a
regulation which we hope will be quickly
make progress in terms of
adoption a regulation on cross-border
assistance particularly with the ongoing
evolution of the of the virus the
appearance of new virus it's important
that the work that we're doing there
with the objective to improve our
cross-border assist assistance can be
quickly translated into law into
regulation so that work is ongoing in
addition to that you will also remember
that we have established here
which is an authority the main task of
which is to help us with a better
preparedness for um for crisis and to
if need be
be in a better position to quickly
negotiate contracts get into touch with
private sector public sector to make
sure that we are better prepared for the
next crisis so work is ongoing and we
hope that particularly on the
cross-border assistance
regulation
soon we can go to adoption thank you
thank you are there other questions for
us on health
yes please
thank you
my question is regarding um the omicron
variant precisely um yesterday uh in the
statement of the commission president
van der lion said that
the european union would deliver 700
million doses to low-income countries
so by mid-2022 as deadline so i want to
know
given the origins with the omicron
variant if that strategy is ongoing
right now and how it's going to be
delivered uh but given the current
origins how it's going to be developed
thank you stephan thank you very much um
i think i can say that european union
has always been on the forefront to
build a global solidarity we were aware
from the beginning that as long as the
virus was not
uh tackled all over the world the virus
is still out there and we're not safe i
would say so we this is uh requires a
global response
several instruments seven tools have
been developed to do this apart from for
instance um the fact that we export uh
already 1.3 billion dollars to uh the
rest of the world we also have very
strong commitments from what we call
team europe the
member states and the european
commission
team europe has committed to
deliver indeed by the end of this year
250 million doses as was also again
announced by president of wonderland and
then to go up to 700 million by mid next
year and this is part of the ongoing
effort to
deliver these vaccines these are
vaccines that have been developed on the
basis of our advanced purchase
agreements with vaccine developers
these vaccines have been developed for
the member states but member states on
the basis of these advanced purchase
agreements donate them to other parts of
the world where there is also a high
need for vaccines thank you
sorry follow-up apologies
um i have another question well
regarding uh kovacs for example uh last
week i spoke with the special envoy for
uh coffee 19 at the who and he told me
that
kovacs mechanism is not receiving the
vaccines that it needs
for example when uh united states and
here's well uh people is receiving
boosters
so uh how the european union can help
kovacs to receive the vaccines that it's
supposed to receive in order to help
low-income countries
well the mechanism that we use is that
we set up agreements with the
manufacturers of the vaccines and the
member states and corvettes the
commission is trying to play i would say
a facilitating role here to make sure
that such agreements took place
last week for instance as you know we
announced that such a trilateral as we
call it agreement was concluded with the
johnson johnson kovacs and then on
behalf of the member states again the
objective of this agreement being to
facilitate donation by member states
of vaccines produced under the advanced
purchase agreements to kovacs we have
similar agreements with moderna with
similar agreements with biontech pfizer
so the mechanisms are put in place to
make sure that these deliveries which
are ongoing can take place thank you
thank you yes
yes i have two questions regarding the
easy dc
when you look into the proposal online
it says that the part of the new role is
that it'll uh
be tasked with coordinating a new
network of union reference laboratories
for public health
my first question is what information is
going to be flowing through this network
the other one is that it also further
downstates
that
part of the initiative will be to
reinforce the eu commitment to global
health security preparedness i hope you
might be able to in layman's term
explain what that actually means
um
thank you very much you know the
proposal that we made for to strengthen
the ecdc was based on the fact that ecdc
first did an extremely good job but that
there are elements that we could improve
to make the preparation for future
pandemics even better and one of the
elements on which uh the with which the
regulation or the proposal tries to give
an answer is the fact that we should
have better data management data coming
from the member states for instance
through better collection of data and
also through contacts through networks
with different representatives so the
objective is to set up a system that
allows to closely follow what is
happening in the member states using
clear data clear reporting mechanisms on
the basis of which the different experts
together with the ecdc can do i would
say a strengthened surveillance
of the of the situation and it's all
part of this
idea to make the mandate of the ectc
stronger thank you okay we now turn to
the interaction platform we continue on
uh health issues joao
we cannot hear you
you need to change your might source or
press speak
uh yes and now yes go ahead okay so uh i
wonder if you have already analyzed the
decisions taken by the portuguese
authorities to face the pandemic
particularly that's related to the need
for negative tests for the passengers
arriving by flight even those uh having
a valid covid certificate
under the needs
for coordination
do the portuguese authorities
give any justification to impose the
measure do you consider that this is a
proportionate measure
and
finally um
what are the conditions for seen under
the rules of certificates allowing the
member states to activate emergency
brakes and impose additional measures
thank you that's like half a dozen
questions
in one joao i think you have broken the
press room record
there
before we give the floor uh to christian
on this uh let me see if there are other
questions uh for stefan on health
specific issues and not freedom of
movement within the eu but we'll come
back to your question joao on health
issue because uh you have referred to
solidarity the eu practices but it's
exactly the opposite to what president
of south africa cyril ramaphosa said he
said that uh there is a lack of
solidarity there is a breach of
solidarity because south african uh feel
that they are punished for excellent
work of their scientists tracing omicron
micro
uh that's virus let's call it virus
yes thank you well
you will have seen that yesterday in her
speech to the world health assembly
uh president van der laan explicitly and
warmly
thanked the south african authorities
for the impressive work
that they have done
in identifying the omicron variant i
think that everybody recognizes the
importance of this work in terms of
helping the world community to
stem as far as possible the um
the development and spread of this
of this variant of course a certain
number of precautionary measures
had to be taken
not to stop the variant from
reaching europe or indeed other parts of
the world i think everybody recognizes
that
that is not possible but to ensure
that
we
slow down its spread as much as possible
in order to give european health
authorities
our pharmaceutical suppliers of vaccines
the time to adapt um and ensure that we
can then roll out an appropriate
response in the in the proper manner let
me remind you as well that uh the
european uh union uh has been
cooperating closely with um with south
africa
um in particular when it comes to
developing uh vaccine uh production in
the country so it's a very difficult um
situation uh we recognize obviously the
burden that this puts on all the
countries
affected it is a responsibility of the
european union authorities of course
to act in a manner that allows us to
protect the health of european citizens
as much as possible but we will continue
to cooperate with south africa
in the coming weeks and month in order
to
in order to
stem the flow of the variant and fight
the pandemic
i see no other questions on the health
dimension and therefore we go back to
joao's long list of questions related to
the freedom of movement
within the eu
let me see how i can help you with your
long list of questions with my big pile
of lines
so on
on your question on on the
measures
announced by portugal
as i said as i said yesterday
the portuguese authorities
have
informed us
and not have notified us
about these
intended measures as is also foreseen in
the eu
digital coverage certificate uh
regulation
and we are currently looking into this
notification and and analyzing this
um i don't have any particular uh update
to give uh since yesterday
when it comes to
the question of
the emergency break
this is indeed something that is
foreseen
in
the
council recommendation uh for a
coordinated approach
on free movement and which foresees that
member states can
introduce travel measures um or
additional restrictions if the
epidemiological situation deteriorates
rapidly or very high prevalence of
variance of concern or inter rest has
been reported so this is
something that is
foreseen in the in the coordinated
approach
and but in terms of procedure i mean
basically um
it would be for
for a member state um
to
to announce this to um like this to the
other member states and then it would be
discussed
and in the relevant
formats uh notably
uh the ipcr
and probably the other other relevant
formats
so this is this is where it stands i'm
not sure i have answered everything let
me know if i forgot something
thank you are there other questions for
christian on freedom of movement
in the eu
that is not the case other issues for us
today
no thank you very much and see you
tomorrow